before i begin i feel it is necessary to
point out that the news arm of the bbc
has yet to retract apologize or
otherwise address the deeply transphobic
reporting it has engaged in in the last
few months in a pinned comment down
below you'll find my original video on
the topic several videos from the
youtuber sean who has been ongoing in
his pursuit of trying to get the bbc to
own up to what they have done and also a
video from laura kate dale showing the
protests that have taken place outside
of the bbc offices while i don't feel
any of the people behind doctor who are
in any way responsible for this i cannot
in good conscience talk about a bbc
owned property without mentioning this
first until such time as it is properly
redressed thank you
not sure i trust him now
[Music]
working our way through series 11 and
we've arrived at curblam i was actually
going to be
really curious to revisit this one
because
um my memory of it
pretty positive thinking back i think i
largely fell in love with the energy of
it i it just felt
like what i wanted i kind of like how
ghost monument felt closer to what i
wanted in overall tone despite its
numerous plot and various conveniences
and
issues that it had it still had the vibe
that i wanted more so than something
like rosa or something like the woman
who fell to earth
curblam captured a vibe that i liked and
i remember liking it at the time
now
since then i've seen a lot of very harsh
criticism basically uh calling it an
episode that is a defense of amazon and
that the doctor has become like some
kind of hyper capitalist or something
like that
and having not re-watched it with those
criticisms in mind
i don't think that's fair
i don't think the episode
pulls off
what i think it was maybe trying to do
okay so
especially we'll come back to this i'll
probably focus more on this later but
like especially as far as
the overall moral and philosophical
stance of the episode
it's very confused not confusing
confused it's doing things that seem in
contradiction from what it seems to want
to do and there's even kind of by the
end a little bit of a both sides kind of
thing which normally would turn me right
the hell off except i have a i can't
prove this but i have a very strong
suspicion
that happened by accident
i'll talk more about that when when we
get there but let's just kind of talk
about it as we get through it weird
thing right off the bat it actually
really really really
bothers me
that the curblam man could not only just
teleport inside the tardis which
you're not supposed to be able to do but
they were very clearly in
the time tunnel or whatever the heck it
is that the tardis is flying through and
the kerblam man tracked them through
that
why
it has zero relevance to the story that
it was able to track them across time
and space like the parts that make sense
like if i forgive the teleporting inside
the tardis and i just accept it's been
trying to deliver this package for a
while but he keeps missing the doctor
because the doctor doesn't stay put
isn't always in the right time zone et
cetera but to actually see this thing
catch it through time like
this this annoys me for the same reason
that i got a little bit annoyed at the
uh super advanced fuel that ultimately
became heather in the pilot back in
series 10 which is that
it kind of trivializes time travel
like
in that case it was like fuel just fuel
not even a ship just fuel was so
advanced that on its own it could cross
all of time and space
and here we have delivery robots that
can
teleport inside of a ship that is
generally presented as being
impenetrable and do so while it appears
to be trying to shake it off through
time
it just
it kind of makes like i'm not one of
those people who thinks only the time
lord should be able to time travel i
actually don't think that but i don't
think time travel should be so common
that it trivializes what the time lords
are the fact that they can time travel
is honestly in a lot of ways almost the
only notable thing about the time lords
it's in the name so when i see something
as mundane as package delivery appearing
to make use of it i'm like
that's a small thing to get hung up on
that doesn't bode well
anyways now that the blame man's there
let's address the doctors uh let's just
go with glee and almost a certain sense
of awe that she has at the curblam man
and what is
really very clearly framed as
effectively space amazon
[Music]
you're just making sounds now it does
admittedly feel a little bit weird that
the doctor is
so excited and so praising of
just this epitome of capitalism standing
in her ship and delivering something and
like it's not even that she's excited to
get the present which it being a fez is
kind of cute and i like how that muddies
the idea of what regeneration even
ordered this dang thing implying it was
the 11th but who knows um but so that's
a touch i like but she's not even
excited about what she got she's so
excited just about
curblam
and the curblam man that does admittedly
feel a little off that having been said
there's two things i'll say in defense
of that
one broadly speaking
the doctor does not always have to 100
line up to what previous incarnations
i've done there are definitely earlier
incarnations of the doctor who would be
way down on this the doctor just
restricting to the modern era has
badmouthed everything from you know as
far as modern conveniences like blogging
twitter and just the previous series
which is part of what makes it a little
bit awkward at least as far as timing
goes
peter capaldi's doctor
had a lot of very nasty things to say
about capitalism that was kind of a
recurring running issue it came up in
thin ice it was central to oxygen the
end point of capitalism
bottom line where human life has no
value at all
so
seeing the doctor being like oh i love
this
massive corporation that just sells
stuff and delivers it to people like
you love it you what like it does feel a
little off but i think part of that is
just proximity to capaldi series 10
which can still be considered a minor
fault but more importantly
narratively
it's okay if the doctor is a little more
enthusiastic than maybe we think she
should be because that
can give her an arc to realize this
thing that she thought was good actually
has issues now some people might make
the argument the doctor should already
know the problems with something like
curblam that's kind of a separate
conversation but just broadly speaking
she's not perfect she doesn't have to be
she can be wrong about things
every doctor can i think most doctors
should be wrong probably a little bit
more often than they are especially in
the modern era but
uh there is not an inherent problem as
far as telling the story with her being
excited about it as they're about to go
to the plant she's gonna get a wake-up
call on how this thing really runs
does she actually get that wake-up call
that's a little hazier but as far as
setup goes there isn't a problem with
that in and of itself now once we get
there this is actually probably one of
the best instances of ryan's dyspraxia
being brought up and addressed because
well actually first of all they use
ryan's actual um working background
working in a warehouse as a good bit of
character moment you see his just
disappointment that they're out of
warehouse and you see his reservation
about like i'm
this is what i'm trying to escape this
is part of what i'm trying to escape
from by traveling with the doctor this
is really what i'm going to be doing he
actually plays that really well and his
dyspraxia comes up because you know it's
noted by keira we'll come back to her uh
it's noted by kira that he's doing a
very good job and wrapping the items
putting them in the boxes and and all
that and he notes that it takes me a
while to learn things physically get
there in the end but just some stuff
takes me a bit longer
luckily i had mates recovered to me in
the beginning that actually is a very
organic situation that brought up
not just his dyspraxia again but not
only reminded us of it but gave us a
reason why it wouldn't apply in this
situation and at least to my very
limited understanding of dyspraxia it
tracks or at least it makes logical
sense at the very least
which makes it kind of disappointing
that later on in the episode when they
have to like go down the chute he stops
and goes i should let you know i have a
coordination problem
not super serious but you know makes
life
really interesting you already reminded
us in the episode about his dyspraxia in
a much better way why are you now laying
it out just flatly like this but
we get
a couple of characters in this warehouse
and two of the big ones are kira and dan
and both kiera and dan have
death flags for days and unsurprisingly
they both die now if you've been
watching this take two review series you
might be thinking i'm about to call out
yet again needless cruelty on the part
of uh the writers chipnold didn't
actually write this one himself but on
the part of the script again i'm
actually not this time because i do
think there's a significant difference
between taking the time for us to
actually get to know here i get to know
dan get to see how they are affable
well-meaning how kyra is very
good-spirited how dan is you know
pushing himself forward through a job he
doesn't enjoy but for the sake of his
daughter and he tells lame jokes and
he's just happy to have somebody to
laugh at them these are endearing human
characteristics they give me a sense of
who these are as people
as opposed to the kind of nonsense that
i've called out in things like woman who
fell to earth with the security guard
who had absolutely no story reason to
die where the show takes 10 seconds to
establish that he's a grandfather but
the family that loves him will miss him
and then immediately kills him
it's not that characters are dying that
i think is cruel
it is giving us one tiny detail just to
make just to like twist the knife and be
like oh he's got a family and then
immediately killed him that's
lousy as far as i'm concerned this is
not that
dan and kira are well performed we have
enough time with them to actually get
attached to them that even though
honestly like i said they do have death
flags for days especially by doctor
who's standards
they uh
they are missed
i miss them when they're gone
and not in a oh god that why did you
even do that like i felt with that
freaking security guard but i'm
genuinely like oh
that's a shame this is better i feel
like i want to point out the curblam
man's actually a really good design
because like it's very clear the thought
process that went into it making it
friendly and smiling and like evokes
that sense of yeah that has the elements
that people would find
uh appealing and make it seem friendly
and personable but you know just a
little change in lighting a little
changing angle and boy
that that's really sinister actually
it's it's well it's well designed and
it's well shot another thing is good the
music actually stood out to me in this
one i thought the music was quite good
as well and i haven't mentioned the
music too much except for in rosa where
it annoyed me but
the general tone of the music in this
era has been just to be more ambiance it
stood out to me a little bit more here
it's not quite at murray gold bombast
levels but
i liked it something i've noticed about
the sonic screwdriver while she does use
it a lot it's not really being deployed
as a magic wand in the way that it got
accused of being under someone like say
matt smith and what i mean by that is
what she primarily uses it for is stuff
that either has been firmly established
that the sonic can and will do such as
unlocking things
but other than that
the main thing is used for is just data
gathering she waves at something and
then checks it because it basically
translates or pulls out whatever data
she needs so it's not really being used
as a solution to the situations
most of the time it's just how she's
accessing information they don't
otherwise have which that's a pretty
restrained and decent use of the uh
sonic screwdriver i noticed it mostly
here but thinking back i'm like no
that's mostly how it's been used okay
so let's start dealing with the ending
which is where things get very confused
and
again i can't prove this but i have a
very strong suspicion that the starting
pitch for this thing started with that
twist the twist being that it wasn't an
employee asking for help it was the
system asking for help because honestly
that is a twist you can build the story
around and secondly that's a
legitimately good twist
because it's a pretty standard thing for
not only doctor who but a lot of sci-fi
to go and realize oh no the system is
the villain you know even though we've
presented you with this human villain
who looks like he's going to be the
problem that was his name slade or
something the management guy like ooh
he looks sketchy like oh but it's the
system and this actually does kind of do
that but then it goes one layer deeper
and goes no the system has been reaching
out and has been doing some stuff but
it's because it wants help to deal with
something that it is aware of but is
powerless to stop that legitimately is a
decent twist and it's even decently
executed here so i very strongly suspect
that the original core of this was that
pitch and then the story was built
around it
in a way that resulted in some issues
because what i've been avoiding talking
about up to now
is charlie our actual villain so charlie
is a maintenance man and he has he has
basically snuck his way into the curblam
with the intent to make it appear as if
the system failed on such a massive
scale that they would have to dismantle
it because it gets addressed repeatedly
throughout this episode that there are
not enough jobs to go around and the
only reason that curblam even has 10
percent human workforce is because they
are required to
so
there are tons of people who don't have
jobs don't have work it's being done by
machines and he sees a company like
curblam as an embodiment of that problem
so
here's where things get confused and
muddled because again i've seen people
make the claim that because charlie is
ultimately the villain and he's uh
someone basically going
you know we need work workers rights etc
that this is
again somehow intentionally praising
corporations amazon in particular
because this is like an analog for them
and demonizing attempts to improve the
work environment i don't think i don't
think any of that is intentional because
honestly
the way the warehouse is shot and
everything about the times that we see
the doctor and the companions working in
this space pushes on you the fact that
this is an oppressive work environment
you are being monitored all the time you
have you know i brought up the aspects
of keira and dan you know kara having a
very bright outlook but she has to she
points out when i feel sad i think of
people being happy when they receive
these packages she has to think about
that because otherwise the
oppressiveness and repetitiveness of
this job will get to her and dan has to
think about his kid because otherwise
he's going to realize i am losing the
years of my life walking around a giant
freaking warehouse it is at no point
portrayed as a good place to work and
the management is shown to either be
semi-incompetent or too distrusting of
anybody to open up with what they know
isn't right
so i don't think this is at any point
framing
curblam as a good thing
however
once charlie gets introduced it all gets
really muddied so
again this is why i suspect that that
original pitch of but it's actually a
human villain and it was the system
seeking help
kind of throws everything out of whack
because if you're gonna have a human
villain well it has to be doing
something in opposition to the system
and this kind of is a logical way to
take that but there's a number of
problems the first is and we've got a
few to go through here the first is
charlie is a straw man and that's the
price to change how everyone on gundoga
sees technology then it is worth it for
the cause
charlie is an unreasonable human being
his conclusion that it is worth killing
who knows
how many hundreds thousands millions we
don't know
people is justified
just to try and get people more jobs
and that is ridiculous because even the
most hardcore workers rights individuals
generally aren't saying and we are
prepared to
to not just allow but ensure that people
die to get what we want because that's
that's the other thing like he's
he's doing terrorism so it's already
pushed him over the top and he's just so
unreasonable like to the point that he
doesn't even try even after he realizes
his plan isn't gonna isn't gonna work
and all these things are about to blow
up around him he doesn't even try to
leave he stops being a character as soon
as he's revealed to be the villain and
becomes
a straw man i don't think intentionally
i don't think he's meant to be a straw
man of you know unionization efforts or
or anything like that but he becomes one
by the necessities of making him the
villain and i kind of mentioned before
that the episode kind of tries to both
size it with the conclusion in the coda
and i'm going to propose that coupon
becomes a people-led company in future
majority organics and that's treated and
framed like a solution to the problem
but it's not it again it feels like
they're trying to they're trying to
validate charlie's anger if not his
actions but the problem is his entire
perspective was already wrong and this
solution
doesn't fix the problem and i don't mean
it doesn't fix the problem because well
will that create enough jobs that
everyone who needs a job will get one
that's not the problem either
this thing fails to realize what the
actual problem with its scenario is
it's not that all the robots are doing
the jobs therefore people aren't working
and aren't making money and are
destitute
the problem is if all the jobs can be
automated
why are they still living in a system
that requires people to work in order to
make money to live when there is no
reason for human beings to do that
work that's the actual problem the
problem is not there aren't enough jobs
the problem is
why do people still need jobs at all
because by every indication
they don't not more than a handful
because it's all automated and there's
nothing wrong with automation unless you
fail to make the adjustment that we've
automated everything so people don't
have to work and then you alter the
society so that
people don't have to work and clearly
here they still do you have that
hr woman
saying you know so grateful to have a
job right you'll know how they are to
come by and i think it was kira who said
something along the lines of well it
gives us purpose right and like these
are mentalities and these are thoughts
that exist and are pushed especially by
people in control of major corporations
and major swathes of the economy in the
world in which we live so i'm not
criticizing that those things were said
those things should have been said but
the problem is
nobody
points out
that there's no need to require people
to work
that having been said i don't want you
to think that i needed them to suggest a
completely new system to work over or to
work under at the la in the last what
two minutes of the episode because that
basically would mean
solving capitalism and that's too much
to put on the end of an episode i mean
oxygen as much as i love it kind of
ended up making that mistake back in
series somewhere but as far as i
remember there's a successful rebellion
six months later
corporate dominance in space is history
that about wraps it for captains uh
that's an overreach which is a shame
because that episode's awesome so i'm
not saying that's what they should have
done but somebody
somebody
whether it's the doctor any of the
companions heck it could be the
management guy or the hr lady somebody
to at least point out
we really should be pushing to change
the system so that
the robots can just do the jobs and we
aren't left destitute
by not working and something that i
noticed while editing was this we're
suspending all operations for a month
pending review and while the teammates
are rebuilding dispatch all our workers
have been given two weeks paid leave did
you catch that they're shutting down for
a month but paid leave is only two weeks
and nobody realizes that's not right
this thing's attempt to criticize
capitalism while being embedded in the
ideas of capitalism and not recognizing
so many of these things being wrong
fundamentally is
infuriating
i just need somebody to point out that
they understand that
because again
everybody
is
charlie
in what he's trying to do is the villain
and also like this supposed solution at
the end is addressing the wrong problem
and that's not a failure or a
mischaracterization of the doctor it's a
failure of the writers to recognize the
actual scenario they created and the
thing was almost onto something when the
doctor says the systems aren't the
problem how people use and exploit the
system that's the problem which
depending on how you mean that in the
context of it i actually can't agree
with systems once in place actually are
a problem in and of themselves they can
be absolutely but systems are created by
people and people create the systems
that are oppressive and perpetuate those
systems so she is right that people are
the problem but then she says to charlie
people like you
what no look charlie's an idiot and he's
a straw man like i said but he's not the
oppressors in the society
nothing about him indicates that he's
the kind of person who would ha would
have had the power the authority or the
thought process to put a system like
kirblam into place in the first place
he's not the problem the people who
orchestrated this in the first freaking
place and are profiting off it as it
currently exists
they are the problem charlie is a
problem but he's not that problem
and one more thing about the doctor's
apparent love of the system we get this
kablam's system does have a conscience
he's been fighting you charlie it knew
it which is a huge leap of logic with a
core fundamental problem which is
willingly put kira in danger and allowed
her to die it doesn't have a conscience
it's fighting back charlie because
charlie's trying to break it he's trying
to break the system it's in
self-preservation mode it doesn't have a
conscience and again despite as worked
up as i am i don't think the episode is
purposefully trying to like big up
amazon's your friend because again the
framing of working there is not pleasant
in any way shape or form but it's what i
said at the beginning it's confused
it doesn't seem to realize what the
actual moral message of this
could be or should be given the setup
they've created either they needed to
alter the setup so that this framing was
not as tone-deaf or they needed to
change the framing into something that
makes sense and actually addresses the
freaking problem or at the very least
don't pretend like you fixed it because
you didn't
this episode is
frustrating
because like i said there's a lot that's
good here
this is some of the best
characterization for the incidental cast
that we've gotten the companions are
well utilized the doctor gets some
clever bits of banter back and forth
here and there like i said i like the
vibe and the energy of it it has a
rollicking adventure feel that i really
enjoy
but
oh boy
it either thought it was making a
different point than it was or nobody
like stopped and really thought wait
what point are we making here and just
let it lie in this
mishmash state that it's in
frustrating
this could have been great as it is it's
almost good
curblam
what'd you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it
patreon it's how i pay the bills and i'm
able to do this as my living any amount
you're able to donate there is of great
help but even if you can't like share
subscribe help me out and there's links
to other things that i do such as twitch
tick tock i have books that are for sale
merch etc etc but
don't worry too much about it what i
really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you're the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
hey end credits time which means i need
to shout out some patrons this time i'm
going to be shouting out robin moore
zubin lutfalla turok oliver b melinda
walters
the oath of boy tt for nabi lax the
poodle zach paul idolin tracy scrapped
vincent paul bartolucci angry casper
toku b.l whovian adam rdl taylor shane
ross shaylee gourley and brendan the
rose you want to hear me mispronounce
your name check out rewards on the
patreon
thanks for all your support
[Music]
foreign
[Music]